my name is I believed you I'm from Haiti
I mean at least remember would
absolutely sir my scripture I'm walk we
would do first and then after that I
mixed together all the material I'm shy
and the sweet little are retired behind
sometimes I'm used Emile behavior both
and both head chopped off so I'm recycle
everything nice easy to confuse confirm
anything graphics a second hand for
example beautify the show's spoon fabric
what is a cabbage from unalakleet Canada
you have get it and I'm use this on my
work when I'm use the curve and my work
and the religion is a giddy amazing
represent death and life analytic
realize it cause we Heidi death master
after happy so you know to have collapse
and then on the concrete you can fight
the body I'm used like the body Natalie
head and then split squad and abused
that in my wall
if you're poor man Julian in my heart I
didn't we i believe you know you know
Robbie electricity to have a food and
function seat if you go to the hospital
God meet someone for Spain in an issue
have something like this you would be
dying really bored easily quito for me
I'm resisting I'm fighting for this week
that the reason are against a group give
it a name at least editor one more
download the AJ plus mobile app and join
the conversation available in your app
store now